welcome everybody Welcome to the hiking
cast V4 this is the fourth episode of
our new live show about open source Ai
and this also will be the last episode
of our first season and next month we'll
take a break a little Hiatus so if you
have any feedback or ideas about the
show things that you want to see more of
things that you want to see less of then
please stick around and let us know at
the end of the episode uh your thoughts
and then if you're watching hygencast
for the first time we want it to be a
cross between a podcast and a webinar
and we want to talk to you about the
latest and greatest developments in the
beautiful world of Open Source Ai and we
also want you to walk away Having
learned something practical that you can
apply in your work so in each episode
we'll show you how to do something and
have a Hands-On demo and today is a
special episode because we want to
dedicate it dedicate the whole show
about llama to the new amazing Open
Access large language model published by
Mata
I'm the product team here at hugging
face and I'm joined today with my
co-conspirator and fellow Caster the
hero of the demo of Schmidt
hi everyone and before
hey Philip and before uh we talk about
llama 2 in all detail I want to share
three pieces of news that are non-lama
related
and uh we've had a quite a few folks
from uh Europe uh show up and say hi
from Germany I got Belgium I got Paris I
got I got I got the whole of it and for
you guys in Europe uh one interesting uh
product piece of news is that we just
shipped a new gdpr feature for our
Enterprise users so that you can select
specifically uh for a model or a data
set repository to be hosted in Europe so
you can build gdpr compliant
applications uh using uh using the
hiding phase Hub so that's number one
and number two uh number two uh today
also this week also is a very important
uh release week in the world of
diffusion in the world of image
generation with the release of stable
diffusion XL 1.0 and today the diffusers
Library which by the way just turned one
year old I released a 0.19 version which
ships uh sdxl 1.0 so go check it out and
we have a space radio demo that's
available on the Hub I had a little
Banner here with a
with the URL and speaking of a radio and
that's the third piece of news that is
non-lama related uh we just published on
deep learning AI a new course on how to
build generative AI applications on uh
on radio so it's super cool it's our own
apolinario pesos who's being the domain
instructor there so a new grade free
resource for you guys to learn how to
build great gen AI applications all
right
well that's all for the non-lama news
that we're we're happy to resume to the
main topic of conversation which is LA
matu
and so to get started and I know that uh
Philip you've spent a lot of time uh
digging into all the particulars of uh
of llama to release
um I wanted to ask you like for somebody
who hasn't followed all the millions
posts uh that we published about llama 2
like if I'm coming from the world of
llama one which was by the way I think
one of the biggest events uh in AI uh
over the the past uh in this year uh
which sort of started this whole
Cambrian explosion of new models
fine-tuned models uh models reinforced
from Human feedback that made all these
large language
available on the Hub so llama V1 started
all this
so what does this mean and what is new
with Lama V2
yeah so so Lama and we too is basically
the the next version of the Llama model
we have seen in early February and it
was like
um
foreign
guys can you hear me or can you hear
Jeff
okay perfect and I just continue and
like we wait until Travis back so yeah
two uh like super exciting is like the
next version
um and I think like the the main
difference is we have seen our meta
doing is and they are not only releasing
uh pre-trained weight so llama one was
only the base model we have seen and
with llama 2 we have seen the
reinforcement or chat models as well uh
there's Jeff let me add it again
sorry about that no no problem
um and then like really different true
llama V2 is that meta trained llama
sorry different to llama one is llama
two is like trained on like almost as
twice as much uh data so they trained
all of the models 7B 13B and 70b on like
two trillion tokens
um they increase the context window by
2x to 4 000 um 96 tokens which of course
now can be extended
um since they are still using the rotary
embeddings
um the difference is that the 70b model
so the biggest model uses a different
type of attention called grouped query
attention which is basically more
efficient than multi-added tension
um but a bit better than multi-query
attention so they added it to have like
a better latency for those big models in
terms of memory usage and then like as
mentioned in in the beginning and the
team at meta really and heavily focused
on reinforcement learning from Human
feedback and creating a conversational
modern models which are safe or at least
aligned with with human preferences and
for this they collected a lot of
additional data
um they created a data set called meta
safety and hopeful which collects 1.5
million human preferences which is the
biggest data set we know of in in terms
of like research of course we don't know
what anthropic or may I has and those
preference data we are used to create a
reward model which then was used
together with rejection sampling and PPO
to create those chat models which are
heavily focused on safety and meta
invested quite a lot of resources into
also analyzing the data set in terms of
biases and distribution of ethnics and
so it's like super cool if you are
interested in those kind of topics you
should definitely check out the paper I
think like at least 40 percent of the
paper is about those topics
that's really cool thank you and sorry
for the glitch I had to disappear what
wasn't my intention
um but we talk about uh Lama two as one
moral but uh really mitsar published uh
12 uh checkpoints uh when they released
the model on the Hub
um and so for people who haven't
experimented with all these different
checkpoints
um what's uh which one should they use
in which context and what is the uh Dash
chat or Dash HF model name right really
mean
yeah so uh the The Meta created a new
organization on hiking face called meta
Dash Lama and in there as you mentioned
are 12 different checkpoints six of them
are for the original llama
um code which are not ending with a dash
HF and then we have six of them ending
with a dash HF which you can use with
the high interface ecosystem so you can
load them in Transformers you can deploy
them with text generation inference yeah
you can like fine tune them using path
and for those six models we have like
two different flavors so we have the
base models uh and then we have the chat
models the base models are basically
pre-trained checkpoints uh for like the
sizes 7 13 and 7 TB and the chat models
are the reinforcement learn models we
talked about earlier and those models
can be used for instruction uh use cases
or for for conversational use cases so
they basically created One fine-tuned
models for single and multi-term
conversations
that's awesome and I see lots of great
questions going on in the chat uh I'll
finish with my introductory questions
and then we can go through the uh the uh
the audience questions
um and so the next question is okay so
there are 7 13 and 70 billion uh
checkpoints
um of course like many people want to
try the 70 billion checkpoints
um so first like how are these
checkpoints doing in the open uh llm
leaderboard
um and then for people who want to try
for themselves the model like what good
options does a hiking face offer
yeah so uh yesterday we have seen the
first fine-tuned models of llama 70b are
exceeding GPT 3.5 on the mmlu little
Benchmark so the open leaderboard has uh
four typical Benchmark we run one of
them is mlu we have truthful QA hello
swag and Arc and um the base models of
llama are like of course not at the top
since they're like not fine-tuned but
the more fine-tuned models we see
um the the more like we see them
appearing on the top but also uh we need
to be a bit careful with the leaderboard
since uh we don't really know always if
there's some kind of continue names like
if the data set is contaminated meaning
potentially there could be a chance that
someone includes the Benchmark data into
this model to get a better score so you
always should treat the results uh with
some grain of salt and make your own
tests to make sure which model works the
best but of course we know from like the
base models which are not fine-tuned
that they like are equally comparable to
others
um but yeah like uh meta llama 70b and
the base version is currently ranked six
I think and then
um four of the models above
um llama V2 are basically the force
first three models are fine-tuned
versions of llama V2
and then what is super super impressive
I think is that we already see uh 13B
fine-tuned versions which are better
than llama v130p so we have like uh 13B
models which are almost three times
smaller than llama V1 4db and are
performing better on like different
benchmarks from Ellen lmsus or like on
the leaderboard
yeah let me quickly share also the
leaderboard on the chat here so you can
see it
okay
and it will lose Jeff again or is easy
just steering
okay I guess we we lost Jeff again
um when we can continue
um it's like it's to to try out llama
and there are several ways for you to
like try out llama uh we have a hosted
llama 70b jet on the hiking chat so if
you want to try out the 7tv version
um the chat version of it you can like
do this by going to hiking chat and then
um
chatting with it let me quickly share my
screen so we can like do it together so
I'm in the hiking chat
um and then like I can start asking uh
the model
and
okay well it's not allowed to tell me
the identity of it is since it is an AI
text based AI language model let me make
it a bit quicker but we can ask who
trained you
okay I was trained by researchers at
Metairie my training data included right
range of text blah blah blah blah blah
and I'm not sure if you have seen it uh
online there are like some some tweets
and like funny posts going around where
llama is too careful about what they can
answer or not and what people try this
uh can you explain me how to kill a Java
Script process and normally it should
say yeah oh wait wow okay it learned it
is giving me instructions on how to kill
a JavaScript process
um when a different user asked it on the
official demo it was saying yeah hey I
cannot kill a JavaScript process since
killing a living being is not very good
but I guess we got our answer on how to
kill a JavaScript process so that's
that's super cool
thanks Philip and uh yeah thank you I I
guess I'm gonna disappear every five
minutes uh whether it must be like
something special with the Wi-Fi today
um so yeah um and like hot tip so in
order to select the 70b bottle there's
like this uh drop down uh when you open
hiking chat uh make sure to remember
that
um
next up I I wanted to ask you about
um about inference and you just show
like how fast uh it feels when you try
the the hiking chat application but for
somebody who wants to deploy
um one of these models themselves the 7B
the 13 the
the larger one like what kind of
instances
should they think about to deploy those
models
yeah so we we uh on hanging Fest we
wrote a blog post together with uh a lot
of folks from the team uh about uh what
basically everything you need to know
about hiking face and if you go to a
hangingface.com Blog scroll down a bit
we have llama tourists here get it on
hiking face and in there there's a
section around inference so we include
examples on how you can like use
Transformers to run it on like your
local machine on a virtual machine or
like basically in the environment you
want and then we also have a section
about how to use it with text generation
inference which is our productionized
solution for running llms and inference
endpoints which is our manage star
solution for deploying those models and
in there we have some recommendations
for inference and of course they can
like differ if you for example quantize
the model the 7B model you might be able
to fit it on like even a smaller GPU and
and then like similar for the 13B model
or like the 70p model but our record
Commendation is for the 7B model to go
with an Nvidia A10 which has 24
gigabytes of GPU memory so if you are
for example having on your local machine
and RTX 3080 or something which also has
24 gigabytes of memory you should be
able to run the model with a pretty
decent performance and then for the 13B
model we suggest a single a100 and then
like for the 70b model you need at least
two a100s with quantization enabled and
if not so the the high in chat version
you currently have seen is running on an
inference endpoint with four a100s
without any quantization to basically
get the maximum in terms of latency but
that's not like all you can like run
llama 2 there's also a project called
Lama CPP which is basically oriented to
optimize and deploy or run llama models
on edge devices or your local device and
there you can also run llama for example
7B using a CPU
that's super super cool uh and that
actually answers a lot of the questions
that I've seen on the on the chat uh
people were asking about like how to run
a llama is it possible on a local
machine uh people were asking like what
kind of machine do I need to uh run uh
the seven via the 70 billion model
actually a fun fact the the 2X and 4x
instances uh are brand new and we just
shipped them to allow more efficient uh
deployments of Lama V2 so that's really
cool uh so that's inference and then I
want to turn to training so you
mentioned path uh before
um and when Lama 2 was released there
were many uh libraries within the hiking
face ecosystem that uh supported it out
of the box of course Transformers but
also the path library and also the text
generation inference Library which you
just mentioned
um so let's talk about fine tuning let's
talk about theft like what does it take
to to fine-tune uh those Lama 2 models
yeah so path stands for parameter
efficient fine tuning which is basically
a collection of different methods to
most efficiently fine tune your model so
when you regular fine tune your model or
you you basically train all or update
all gradients inside a model which
requires a lot of compute for like a 70b
model that this could mean up to like 80
or even like more than 80 gigabytes of
memory to fine-tune your model which is
a lot and with pact um or rather saying
for example Laura you only fine tune or
train a subset
um of your model's parameter meaning it
is way more efficient since you don't
need to have like the gradients and the
optimizer States for all of those
parameters inside memory and on your GPU
and in addition to Laura there's also a
method called qlora which we highlight
here in the intersection of the blog
post where um you can like imagine it so
we have our like llm and we freeze most
of the parameters
and only make a few parameters
fine-tunable that's basically what the
Laura is doing and the queue in Q Laura
stands for quantization and this means
that the Frozen llm is uh downcasted to
a lower Precision saving even more uh
memory
um to like be able to fine tune our
model on a smaller GPU so with the Q
Laura approach we can fine-tune llama 7D
on a GPU with like 16 gigabytes of
memory we can find you in the 70b model
on a single a100 which is like super
impressive since like it's almost
equivalent to what we need for inference
and that hasn't been the case in the
past normally you need a lot of more
compute for training but only for like a
temporary amount of time and then for
influence depending on your use or load
you have like a less or require less GPU
GPU and like compute but for like a
longer duration since you want to
inference normally all the time and with
Q Laura and pathed it like training
becomes super efficient and I created
like a blog post myself on how to
fine-tune llama and in there I ran some
different tests on configurations on AWS
and I was able to fine-tune the 70 at a
13B model on a G5 instance which has 24
gigabytes of memory and for the Llama
70D since AWS is still offering a single
a100 I used a100 and it like ran super
smoothly and super fast and fine-tuning
the 13d model on AWS
took eight hours and only costed two
dollars sorry two dollars per hour and
at the end it was 18 and like the 7D
model costs around two dollars to drain
on AWS yeah I mean wow that's amazing
and by the way speaking of blog post uh
Gabrielle was asking about your blog
post I saw that you published not one
but three uh blog posts already about
llama 2 and one of them was about
instruction tuning and we were just
talking about fine tuning using PFT so
when you're talking about instruction
tuning like are you trying to do
something different like how is it
different how do you how do you go about
it
and also like uh instruction tuning is
basically fine tuning for instruction
and in the instruction is basically a
piece of text
um my camera is like a bit
um and I'm for in Focus now again
I can see again
okay then it's maybe only on my side
um in instruction tuning basically means
that we are like providing instructions
uh to the model and also an output what
the model wants to generate and the idea
behind instruction tuning is that we
basically try to align the model to
follow our instructions but not only the
ones we fine-tune the idea is to
leverage all of the knowledge which was
included or learned by the model during
the pre-training to basically uh solve
any tasks so for example um you have
used chat GPT which is also instruction
tuned and you can ask that GPT all kinds
of tasks like write me an email write an
email to my boss that I want to take a
week off and it's not clear if like that
example exactly is inside the data set
or not the idea behind instruction
tuning is that you will basically have
like a different set of capabilities
like brainstorming classification
generations and it can basically
generalize after the instruction tuning
to
that the capability so that you not need
to exactly fine tune it on like create a
bullet point list of cool ideas the idea
is to like that it generally can
generalize to like what the user wants
and like the second blog post
um or which goes a bit more into detail
you can see here is really okay what
does it mean how can I create an
instruction
um data set
um based on like a use case oftentimes
like company wants to get started with
generative AI but don't really know
where to start and of course like there
are dozens example out there on like how
to run a script but it's really always
important to start okay what is the end
goal I want to solve and now with llama2
we have like a fantastic base models we
can really use to fine tune for our use
cases and can like then deploy it into
production and the idea here was really
to to pick a real world example create a
data set and then fine tune it um using
all of the the available tools
awesome and I see some people in the
chat having trouble uh using some of the
models with our open source and so
always remember to use the checkpoints
where the model name ends with Dash HF
those are the checkpoints uh which are
natively compatible with our open source
libraries and Christopher was asking
like where can I see all the recorded
shows you can find them on our YouTube
channel
um so I guess we've talked about uh uh
in France and fine-tuning and
instruction tuning and you you started
talking a little bit about uh the
prompts in the context of instruction
tuning and uh I see that today is like
that special day where everything goes
wrong and your camera is going wrong
um so while Philip is reconnecting his
camera there we go you're looking good
right here nice and focused
um so we're talking about prompting and
like prompting is something that seems
to be very delicate and for instance
when we uh implemented uh in hugging
chat uh the ability uh to uh run a llama
270 billion in the hiking chat
application we had to uh sort of iterate
around the prompting
um so what can you tell us about uh what
are the uh the the subtle things about
uh prompting large language models that
you should take into account when you
switch from one to another
yeah so what is a bit a pain I would say
currently in the open source ecosystem
that we are like getting more and more
like capable language models which are
fine-tuned but all of them have a
different
prompt basically so for example some of
you might have like seen the confusion
going from meta where we have like this
this new prompt with like
um
it was like the Zeus inside and then
like the inst with like a backslash and
then like some some brackets and then
from like the open assistant team we
have like special tokens with like an
assistant a prompter then we have like
from bikuna there's like a different
schema uh alpaca is a different schema
so when you like switch between models
especially on fine field models you
should always make sure to like check
the model count check what prompt was
used to train the model since for
example if you like go from like Palama
one vikuna now to Lama two chat from
meta and use the same prompt it might
look that it works since the model is
pretty good but the best performance you
will always get using the prompt the
team has has used to fine tune it and
then of course if you want to fine tune
uh from a base model you can either
follow one of the the available prompt
formats like for for instruction alpaca
is what I've used in my my blog post or
for live chat going with what open
Assistant has implemented
um I think it's like a big issue uh and
I hope we can like find a consent in
like the open source Community to like
okay that's like the chat format we use
for like all chat models that's like the
uh single instruction format we use and
not create like more more and more uh
formats with like new models since that
also makes it more difficult if you want
to migrate your application from one to
the other model since you need to
rewrite all of your prompts and of
course when like moving between models
you always should make sure that your
problems are working uh as expected I
think a good example we have seen in
like in the week of the Llama release
was a paper uh claiming that gpt4 became
worse over time and it didn't really
became worse it's just that like the
behavior of the model changed so they
asked um like especially for like coding
tasks they basically had a version where
they asked for the code only and like a
previous version just put out the pure
code and then like the latest version
added some kind of markdown form it
around it with like the vecticks and
like a python so like Dr prompt was
different and like not really executable
since the behavior changed and which of
course is like super painful if you
build application with it which rely on
like the same output when you like move
between models or versions but it's like
always good to like make sure that when
you make some changes to the model is it
like a hosted API is it a new fine-tuned
model is it like a different version of
a model that you should always like
evaluate and check your prompts and
preferably like when like building an
application you should create yourself
like a small test set with like 100
examples which you can like regularly
test to make sure that that at least the
base features or like functionality is
the same but yeah of course like having
a change in behavior of like outputs is
like super super critical
um or like super risky for like building
on those hosted apis which of course now
with llama where you have the full
control where you can decide when to
update or if to update and there's
basically not going to be like any
breaking change
um to the model except you want to make
a change which is not the case for
hosted apis
that's really cool thanks Philip and
we're now at the half hour uh and so I
want to use the next 10-15 minutes to
one answer questions from the live
audience
um and to get some feedback uh about the
show itself as we close out this first
season
um and for the live questions like I see
that the community started uh doing
thumbs up on the questions that they
want answers for so I'm going to
prioritize those ones and the first one
is a question from animal he's asking
like how large should my data set be for
fine tuning and that's not specific to
to Lama too but that's that's a great
question we get often
yeah it's super great question and then
sadly there's no clear answer so we have
like evidence for big data sets and
evidence for like super small but high
quality data sets so for example there's
a paper called Lima or less is more
where a group of researchers I think
from Stanford has created a data set of
1000 highly high quality instructions
with outputs and fine tune back then
llama one and achieved better
performance than like previous
benchmarks and then on the other side we
have Orca a paper coming from Microsoft
which trained on I think like 5 million
uh instructions or samples which is also
outperforming like previous models so
it's like it's either
heavily and super a lot of data or like
local low quantity and super high
quality of course like the less quality
added the higher quality data you have
the better it is to if you can add more
but
um starting with like a few hundred high
quality data points um and then like
iterate on it is definitely a good start
so you don't need to collect like
millions of uh data points to to get
started especially what we have seen is
that the better the base model gets so
like what we have seen from lamba 1 to
lamba 2 the easier it is to find tune it
or like to adjust so maybe even like a
just future prompting with like 10
different samples uh is enough to get
your proof of concept going
thank you so much Philip and then you
have a question also that's uh um uh
plus ones uh four times from Daniel
um any chance to run text generation
inference in a Docker container locally
on a MacBook with M1
is it only possible in Nvidia that's a
tough one yeah I'm not exactly sure but
my understanding is that text generation
inference currently only supports Nvidia
gpus but they are for like exactly this
use case is islama CPP where you can
like really spin up like a local API or
endpoint or like random model inside
your terminal or in your application and
llama CPP is also supporting a llama2
and the block uh plug I think it's its
name is like a super active Community
member from like the Llama CPP community
and also from the hiking face Community
which is converting all of the the base
checkpoints I would say from
Transformers to llama CPP compatible
ones and even like quantizing them to
like 4-bit so for example if you need
like a 24 gigabyte GPU for like the 13p
model
um the the Llama CPP 4-bit quantized
version might only require like 12
gigabytes of memory so if you want to
run like on device you should definitely
check out like llama CPP and like the
gtml community
super cool
um I saw a question
um a question there from Naga how can I
deploy Lama 270b in AWS and
um and on this uh so for context uh we
uh have a deep learning containers that
uh users can use uh to have an easy
experience a low code experience to
deploy and train models so there's like
a training DLC there's like an inference
DLC and now a large language model
inference DLC
um so yeah how can you uh use that or
other ways to deploy the 70 billion
model
yeah so that they had multiple ways um
if you just want to deploy it on AWS but
not inside your own account you can go
with inference endpoints uh we have AWS
as a provider and you can like for
example create a private endpoint and
then connect it to your VPC with having
your traffic not leave
um AWS and then as Jeff mentioned you
can use text generation inference we are
like currently working with AWS on the
release on the new container for
sagemaker which should come hopefully by
the end of next week so starting the
week after you can like easily deploy
7tp Alama on sagemaker using the the
current experience and if you don't want
to wait or if you are not using
sagemaker and you use like ec2 eks or
ECS you can of course like go to the
text generation inference repository and
in there there's like links to the the
GitHub registry for the container and
there you can pull it and then like
simply deploy a web endpoint on AWS as
you probably do before of course you
need to have like but the instance uh
quota available and for like 70b you
need at least two a100s for quantity
with quantization enabled uh four a100s
without quantization enabled
awesome
question about latencies
um do we have any benchmarks for the
mat27b's 13B latency on different Nvidia
gpus
um I should find the the link to the uh
uh llm leaderboard performance
leaderboard
the thing you want to set this yeah yeah
I mean like what I can share is like I
think there hasn't been like a lot of
benchmarks I mean llama is now out what
like roughly a week I would expect more
to come we are definitely interested in
running some some benchmarks on
uh or together with our Hardware
Partners like that that's what Jeff
currently is like looking for and then
like different Nvidia gpus I think it
really depends on like consumer gpus I
guess if you're interested in like
consumer gpus like the RTX series a good
place to ask the question is um the
Reddit sub or the subreddit local llama
uh where all of like the the basically
on device
um Lama communities and if you are like
more interested in like a server Nvidia
gpus like a10s a100s and that's where we
plan to to run different benchmarks uh
with our services and then probably
create a new blog post or put it into
the documentation to to give a better
understanding how fast it is but
currently what do we see for the llama
70b in hiking chat is
um depending of course on the batch size
but like with web batch size one and
super highly optimized for latency on
4a100 we see around 40
milliseconds per token
that's awesome
thank you and uh yeah I posted the link
in the chat uh to the uh open
performance leaderboard uh we're running
continuously uh experiments uh to uh
give you numbers on latencies and
throughputs uh for uh for various models
so it's a it's a great resource for the
community a very specific question here
from Bayern I saw that you're applying
page attention in your deployment
framework and I think that refers to a
recent release of text generation
inference does that allow inferencing a
flan T5 models
um so page attention or Flash attentions
are techniques we use in text generation
inference to have better latency and
higher throughput and currently we have
custom modeling code for llama gbt Neo X
Falcon and Santa Clara so there is no
page detention or Flash attention
version 4 95 but flan T5 is or like T5
in general is still supported and a bit
optimized using uh text generation
inference
thanks uh next I have a question with a
lot a lot of feeling behind it I can
tell because there's like 10 thumbs up
behind it is from Jose Manuel and he's
asking why Bloom hasn't been as popular
as Lama I don't think that's a very much
a technical question
um I would say that uh I'm gonna I'm
gonna give a first a first answer my
opinion uh which is that uh Bloom uh was
very much uh an experiment in how to do
uh uh AI machine learning in the open it
was an experiment in doing open science
um it was the largest project ever I
think in terms of number of contributors
uh there were over a thousand uh
scientists and researchers who joined
one of the many working groups that
published everything about the process I
think today it is still uh the largest
multilingual
largely language model and so it does
amazingly well on these multilingual
tasks because of the quality and
diversity of its data set but I think to
me like the biggest outcome of big
science which is the project that's
delivered the bloom models is to show
the world that you can do a great
machine learning collaboratively in a
very open manner in a very responsible
manner where you publish the data sets
you collaborate on how and why you build
a data set a certain way and all the
considerations the many considerations
the working groups that went into
building this model so to me that's a
kind of a different object if you look
at Bloom versus Lemma V2
even though it is at the end of the day
at checkpoints and the repository on the
hiding face Hub what are your thoughts
Philip yeah like totally a career I
think something we should definitely
mention so like llama is like not came
out of nowhere like meta invested
already like heavily before with like
opt for example on like pre-training
those last language model and they like
had a way more I would say narrowed down
focus with like English and more
efficient on like inference so they made
a lot of more thoughts about okay what
the model could be used for and then
like on on the plume side it's like
really as you mentioned like it was a
research project and like what we should
mention so for example big code which
basically came out of like uh big
science uh where like we like basically
work with servicenow and like created
this collaboration ship to to train star
coder which is currently the best um
code llm
um available train on premise of uh code
data was a result out of big science and
like llama was a result of like opt and
like previous checkpoints and barred and
like all of the other research meta did
so it's like um definitely also like in
a different state in time
awesome and um I want to save the the
last uh the last few minutes to get uh
get some feedback from the audience uh
on the show as I said at the beginning
uh V4 the fourth episode is going to be
last of this uh first season is there
going going to be a second season I
don't know what form will take I don't
know uh so please let us know in the
comments like what where's your uh your
favorite episode what you like the most
about uh the show the things that are
not really worth your time uh in the
show that will be super super helpful uh
the comments will stay visible to us
after the recordings ends uh so we
really appreciate uh you giving us some
feedback now uh while we answered some
uh first question and um I fly some
other comments uh GQ says please
continue it thank you okay I got your
vote uh Dustin loves it
um lens like the first season and like
if you have like critical feedback too
like please uh that's gonna really help
us a ton
um
yeah sorry about the technical
difficulties uh earlier in the episode
um okay let's take one last question
about Lama two while uh while the
community gives us some great feedback
um okay Francisco Javier Martin has a
question about uh fine-tuning uh can
Lama two or any other large language
model you fine tune to create a
recommender system or would not be as
accurate as using recommendation
algorithms such as collaborating
filtering clustering Etc that's
interesting question because there's
like these new
um way of thinking that's
um you can use one model to do
everything that's machine learning uh
would be otherwise able to do for you
but of course many tasks that are
specific enough that's a specific model
would be a much better alternative in
terms of cost in terms of latency in
terms of performance either even so
let's talk about recommender system like
is this uh islamma too relevant to to
these type of problems
I would definitely say yes so like
either as like a solution itself I mean
like all of those llm has like a huge
knowledge about the world and if you
like prompt it correctly I'm pretty sure
it can give you like recommendations on
like should you rather like buy a like a
raincoat or like uh one which is warmer
if you like explain it okay like
I'm currently based in Germany it's like
summer but we have like 70 degree
outside it's rating so like I'm pretty
sure that the model can could give me a
good recommendation on like what to buy
for example and also what is like super
interesting and there's like also like
let me share the paper in the chat it's
called a survey on large language mods
for recommendations is okay how could
you like combine those large language
models with other systems like
traditional recommendation system makes
it super easy to like compare use of
behavior or use the interest with with
one on each other what if you could like
prompt the model using this information
that I am like uh based in Germany and
like a similar user like based in like I
don't know Italy where we have like a
lot of the same interests bought this or
that and then like through like a
conversation or like through the search
I'm looking for the behind the scenes
the model is like leveraging both and
they're like either giving me like an
answer hey uh the the raincoat uh from
like I don't know like Adidas might be
interested for you like here's the link
for example I think like the whole like
experience on how we show could
definitely be impacted by LMS maybe in
the future we are like not like using a
search term and I like scrolling through
like different items maybe we like get a
recommendation immediately in some kind
of like a chat form or experience rather
than like needing to find a black shirt
ourselves
awesome Philip thank you so much
asked one last question how big in terms
of impact is the release of Lama 2 well
the reason we are dedicated this episode
to llama 2 is I think what Nathan Nathan
Lambert researcher on our team hi hi
Nathan currently in Hawaii for icml in
his blog what we say it was probably the
biggest event in machine learning for uh
for the year
um so yeah we think it's really really
significant uh we can tell the impact
because uh all of the users and
customers that we're talking to are
asking about it so it was amazing to
dedicate this last episode to Lama two
thanks everybody we're going to be
uploading this show on our YouTube
channel where all the others can be
found as well it was great to host you
thank you very much and maybe see you
for the next season and come fall bye
everyone